we interviewed dee wallace I know you
talked to her as well yeah her but we
interviewed her and she said something
that always stuck with me and this was
like two years ago I think we
interviewed her and she said if you
believe the good stuff that people tell
you then you have to believe the bad too
so how do you keep from because it seems
like in this business there's a lot of
black and white there's a lot of oh my
gosh you're great and then there's a lot
of people that you can kind of tell that
they don't think it's great or whatever
it is and it's hurtful so how do you
keep that even keel because I think it
is an interesting thing that she said I
remember when she said in a really
starving why don't you believe the good
that you have to believe the bat and her
point was to kind of just stay neutral
to lot of it and how is that done I mean
that's that's awesome um you know I got
a brief interview with day on the carpet
and yeah I mean she had me tearing up
like there's something about her that
just I haven't read her book yet I don't
know if you have I want to get it's
called bright light which is just
awesome to radio show excellent you know
like that's like oh my god the energy at
that brave heart woman show um yeah it's
funny because I actually experienced
that recently I had I had some peers in
this industry that didn't agree with the
way I handled a situation that had
happened in my career and and some of
the comments I heard where that I had
burned a lot of bridges and that it was
a small town and no one would ever want
to work with me again
and so a little bit of that gets in your
head cuz you start thinking and and you
know things that over here we're like
everybody's talking about it and you
know I'm thinking why I'm not really
talking about it I've only told you know
my closest of closest so if I'm not the
one talking about it then you guys gotta
be the ones talking about it if it's in
your head so then you start thinking
okay well god how many people are
talking about this and how many people
does it affect it so then like you know
you tweet somebody and all of a sudden
they don't respond you're like oh god
dude are they not my friend anymore my
k2 meter do they think I'm a bad person
um so yes it's so hard because at the
end of the day though I have to go but
you know what I also know there's all
this love and I know there's this many
people that love me and there's this
many people and that and this and these
people not people in and this whole
world over here that knows nothing about
this world in that world and so this is
crazy talk right now but like yeah you
have to be like I mean what she said is
true because yeah if you're gonna when
you kind of have to believe the good or
else the bad will take you down you know
um so yeah I think that's maybe where
she's coming from is that to get that
neutral place yeah because if all you
listen to is the good you would be some
kind of egomaniac narcissistic kind of I
don't even know who's an example that's
a good thing and I thought you listened
to was the bad then unfortunately you
know you'd probably have taken your own
life you know I know as artists were
just very sensitive creatures and
there's been times in my life where ya
hurtful things have taken me down pretty
low and for me right now a lot of yoga
I'm trying to get any more meditation
trying to be around more productive
positive spiritual people and these are
the things outside of our industry I
think that we can do to help protect us
to help keep us keep our spirits up to
keep our our obray to to just keep oming
and chanting and go
oh you think I'm a b.i.t.c.h okay Oh
finding sort of the official thing I
think I heard Sandra Bullock one time
say that she can't wait sometimes to
just get out of LA and just put her
hands in the dirt somewhere and garden
or do something that where it has
nothing to do with acting and status and
looks and how much money someone make so
maybe finding something that is not
about that and having that as like your
side yeah yeah no I mean obviously
Sandra's coming from a place where she
doesn't have to work 24-7 to be able to
go do that right I would love to just go
dig in the dirt for a couple months can
I come too um but yeah um gosh and I and
I probably don't do that enough because
even like you know I do try to it when
you spend time with family and and
things like that sometimes you can shut
that off put down the phone and what's
interesting is I've noticed recently
Bonnie Gillespie is a as a mentor and
friend of mine and she tweeted something
recently about she's she it was really
funny it was something like I'm blocking
you not because of you but to save me
from going down the rabbit hole this was
just a general tweet that she tweeted
and i responded to her and I said yes
and another great thing is when you do
block someone I seem to just poof
disappear on your life you know like and
all the sudden you forget that they were
even showing up in your stream of life
whether it be you know online or in the
real world and in a body responds and we
got a laugh out of that and um yeah I
mean I think the other thing is just to
remove anybody that but you know like
just find those good people that are
doing things like the Space Command team
so far is just ridiculously awesome
people like every day that I'm working
with them unlike
you know we're getting stuff done and I
and I think the thing is is I in this
industry I was blessed in the very
beginning of my professional career if
you want to call it you know when I
first got into sag with with the david
milch is in the Seth Green's and the
Mets and ranks and you know of the world
where these people are like awesome like
they're very giving and very generous
and even not having an agent or a
manager you're not going to you're not
worried that your paychecks gonna show
up hello from Deadwood a robot chicken
you're not worried about those things
you're not worried what the contract
says cuz you know it's you know it's
cool thank you know um but then when
you're out here on your own back in this
indie world um gosh it's like every man
woman and child for themselves sometimes
and so you have to really really build a
supportive community of people around
you which is something that Bonnie
Gillespie had helped me formulate she
had a class rules I think she still does
it it's self management for actors is
what it's called now but class rules was
a class that I was in for about a year
and we went weekly I was a roundtable
discussion each week had a focused topic
you know maybe you're talking about
headshots and managers and agents that
week or maybe you're talking about what
your type is away should be going that
week but it was it wasn't about getting
up and doing acting classes so to speak
it was more about building your
marketing tools in your community and
from that we formed a little email list
where you know that somebody on that
list is going to have your back if
you're like hey I need a you know a
second ad for this shoot that we've
heard about or hey I've heard about this
job paying gig over here um and it's
like this your class you know just like
in high school college is there was an
entertainment class I think that kind of
grows together I recently interviewed my
friend Glenn Sobel he's currently on
tour with Alice Cooper he's their
drummer and I'm glad for about 12 years
when he first moved to town and he was
playing with a panco beautiful creatures
and so I got a chance to interview Glenn
this past summer in Philadelphia I do a
little web series called
dream and that was kind of what we were
talking about was like how cool it is to
see like everybody from that 10 years
ago here in hollywood where they kind of
are right now and for me it was a lot of
music people and also my friend Glen is
playing on Alice Cooper my friend DJ
plays with guns and roses and Glen and
DJ used to being a band together and
it's just like I have another girlfriend
that just got off the road with Duran
Duran and another girlfriend that's on
the Cirque du Soleil the Michael Jackson
immortal tour and it's just you you can
always get out of the leg daily
nitty-gritty of the competition and just
take a look around and see like this in
my community this is my class and look
at where we're all going it's a lot of
yoga
you